Jordan peels record-breaking horror
hitch get out is a socially-conscious
thriller that deals with the worst
modern boogeyman of them all racism with
a number one debut at the box office and
a record-breaking performance on
multiple fronts get out as a film to be
remembered and we're here to tell you
it's untold truth fair warning
now's your chance to look away if you
don't want spoilers it's not about the
president get out might seem like a
response to our current supercharged
political climate but Jordan Peele was
working on the idea even before Barack
Obama was elected and afterward he was
intrigued by the country's so-called
post-racial ideal in which people seem
to believe that a black president
represented the total defeat of racism
in the United States Pele wrote get out
as a response to show that not all
racists look like cross-burning Klan
members the original idea what the movie
was to point out this very real horror
we haven't gotten over it's a tribute to
classic horror Pele took inspiration
forget out from other scary movies about
seemingly well-meaning people doing
horrible things like Rosemary's Baby and
the Stepford Wives but the classic
slasher franchise Halloween also worked
its way in not that there's a masked
killer in peels film but both movies
make the white picket fences of suburbia
look awfully sinister Jordan Peele
dreamed up the film's scariest scene
grab a fresh pair of Underpants because
we are about to relive one of this
movie's freakiest interludes
the secret behind this creepy moment
it's straight out of Jordan peels
subconscious based on a dream he had
about walking through a room of people
who all fell silent as soon as he turned
the corner which makes this scene
literal nightmare material the original
ending was much darker if you thought
that the siren and strobe light in this
scene meant the cops were coming to take
Chris away you're in good company with
the film's director the first ending
that I scripted was not as happy
originally Pele ended get out with Chris
taking the fall for murdering roses
family but fortunately he changed his
mind
deciding it made more sense for Chris to
come out on top I was so excited when I
was able to go get the money to go
reshoot the ending that I knew it would
really work
it's a record-breaker get out was an
instant success at the box office taking
first place in its opening weekend
despite strong competition from both a
beloved superhero and a film where
samuel l.jackson battles a giant gorilla
but more importantly Jordan Peele is the
first african-american writer and
director to helm a debut film that made
over 100 million dollars and get out hit
that benchmark faster than any Blume
House picture in history it's in the
zeitgeist rave reviews and box office
records are all well and good but the
true measure of a movie's importance is
whether it spawns a meme like the get
out challenge don't worry it's not as
scary as it sounds but it is harder than
it looks to recreate Marcus Anderson's
fancy footwork in this now famous scene
casting controversies get-out has
enjoyed nearly universal acclaim but
leaving man
Daniel Kaluga faced some criticism from
fellow actor samuel l.jackson i tend to
wonder what would that movie have been
with an american brother who really
feels fans that but Kaluga responded by
pushing back against the false notion
that he hasn't experienced prejudice in
his words this is the frustrating thing
bro in order to prove that I can play
this role I have to open up about the
trauma that I've experienced as a black
person I have to show off my struggle so
that people accept that I'm black no
matter that every single room I go to
I'm usually the darkest person there you
know what I'm saying I kind of resent
that mentality I'm just an individual
the hidden meaning of milk Allison
Williams is a vision of pure evil in
this scene scouting for new victims
while eating Froot Loops and sipping
from a tall glass of milk but two weeks
before the movie came out a group of
white supremacists did their part to
make this moment even creepier when they
hijacked the political live stream by
actor Shia LaBeouf and started chugging
gallons of whole milk to demonstrate
their white pride Jordan Peele wasn't
aware when he wrote this scene that milk
would become such a fraud symbol of
racial hatred but it definitely upped
the ante on the horror Jordan Peele has
big plans for more horror he might have
started out in comedy but get outs
director reportedly has a lot of ideas
for more movies in the genre he calls
social thrillers these movies that are
are creepy but you know humanity is like
the creepiest part at the center of it
details appeals next project are still
under wraps but he says he's got a whole
series of horror films in mind that will
tackle similar subject matter and that's
definitely something for fans to scream
about thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you love to
you